I'm going to do a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little
bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit
of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of
a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a
little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little
Look who it is. If it isn't a couple of losers. Do you like my cover up? I think it's effective.
harlots today. It's my little sensor bar and also if you don't know my name I
think it's effective. Hello hello how's it going? It's going good! Having a good
day today. Lounge in Maxon and Relaxon. We'll listen to a little bit of Kylie
Minogue of some pre-stream prep. I would really like to dance a bunch and just
get real hype before stream. Don't forget to tweet. You're correct. You're
correct. Can't forget. I smell absolutely delicious because I just came out of the
shower and I forgot, boomie with the home, and I forgot I had some of my
favorite lotion left. I really like the smell of pansy from Lush. It's funny
because on my friend it smelled like old lady flowers but on me I
don't know. Maybe it's my pheromones. It just smells absolutely delicious. Oh we
getting raided! Raflin ride! Holy crap! It's Momay! Have fun beating the crabs!
Forever beating back the crabs. How was the monetization stream? Oh did you guys
have a nice dose of Momay feet? Can I get a sniffer? This is me smelling
Strony's feet. Oh god. Smells smells like salty sea brine. Fucking love it!
Momay's monkey feet! I honestly I'm very impressed with her dexterity with her
feet. Like I definitely I don't I could probably hold something but she was
like doing the whole thing where she's like sticking like ASMR tools in your
ear and I was just I was impressed. I just lurked because I was beating my
I mean I mean I was trying to practice my own foot dexterity. So now do your
foot ASMR stream. Yeah I'm waiting for my red high heels to come in. I need to get
my so like I said that was like that picture I took was from like a month
ago. So I need to get my toes done again. Great carpet clenches. Carpet clenches.
Now that that's one. Carpet grippers. Yeah I got I got the watch of my
collards. I got my tights. Now I just need the heels. I still haven't tried on the
cosplay. I need to do that. And if it doesn't fit I might just wear the shirt
unbuttoned and then this this just like I'll just find it try to find it with
mini skirt. Heel dangle. Oh yeah. Love my giant name tag. Thank you. It's my my
cover-up. I think it's doing a pretty good job. It's not transparent or
anything. Carp. I don't know if I would call it like a carpet clencher. Like use
feet for that on a the other type of carpet. That just sounds painful. Like
did you ever like have that one person or friend that could like use their feet
and like pinch you with them? One of my childhood friends would freak me out by
doing that. Maybe that's not what that's why I'm not into feet is because I was
traumatized by my friend pinching you with her monkey feet. So like imagine
like oh my god ASMR roleplay where Shawnee pinches you with her feet as
punishment. Yep yep. Brother can snap with his toes. What the hell? That's just
Is he a mutant? Or is she a Scott? No. She was just blonde white girl.
And she had the she had a valley girl accent.
Very funny. Where is she pinching? Well in terms of Shawnee, I don't know that's up to her.
Sorry. I'm adjusting myself a little bit here. I can use my feet to pick up the small objects
on the other side of my desk. What the fuck? Thank you. Thank you. I have a great sensor.
Ebony Darkness. Ebony. She she uh Shibbony. Shibbony Darkness took over my channel for a
couple of streams yesterday. My cats have the zoomies right now. What are you doing?
Can you chill out and stop chasing her? Oomie's like harassing a sister.
I hope you guys enjoyed her. She was she was pretty cool. She's a little bit too edgy for my
taste. But uh yeah she's nice. Just like um the other other lady that uh was running that one bar.
She can also disconnect her head from her body. It's really impressive. I wish I had that skill
you know. 10 hour stream today. I I think not.
I think not. I think uh just because I don't think I have I'll probably end up rage quitting
especially with the level the portion of the part that we're on for um uh another crabs
event uh adventure. Another crabs treasure. Nine hour stream then. And a lot of fanfic reading
happened. I went done no I went uphill. We were on a straight incline. We talked about you know how
Hogwarts and a squid made beautiful consensual love. Um
can you hear my cats zooming around my house right now? I turn off the filter so you can.
You hear there's a little just like galloping and then they're they're tokyo drifting around
the corners in my apartment. Just don't be bad at video game. Uh that's impossible for me.
Don't run with your wands out. Yeah there was just like scrawny um squid inked everywhere in Hogwarts.
I have some delicious tea. Heard it a little. No.
It's because Fia likes to take refuge by my feet under my desk. I'm like I'm like you know how
when you play tag as a kid or like just some sort of tag related game um you would have like a
home base where you were safe especially if it was like freeze tag or something. That's what they
use me as. I'm not even joking. If I'm in any part of the house and they're running around
Boomi and Fia will use me as like a home base. Hello welcome in.
What literary masterpiece did you miss yesterday? You missed uh 15 chapters of My Immortal and um
the actual castle Hogwarts being uh tentacle banged by a giant squid. So if you ever check
those out go check them out. You know I'm also working on um I'm gonna re uh public I don't
know what the fuck I'm saying. I'm gonna make public that class of 09 VOD that everybody loved.
I'm just waiting to get monetization before I do because I feel like they would go on that and
they'd be like wow this is bad. We thought the other video was bad of class of what this is worse.
That was my cat.
They're zooming. Yeah yeah I gotta gotta sneak it one in. Yeah I don't they they were pretty like
Boomi was chilling next to me and then they just started zooming. Happy Tuesday. It's Tuesday unit!
Rob, Rob is fucking Tuesday. I can fucking say it. It's Tuesday.
First get monetized then get canceled. Um you know my attempt at speedrunning getting canceled has
not worked. I'm very surprised by that. It's Chokshik Tuesday. She'd be Tuesday. I'm really
excited to hopefully be um do the monetization stream and do like member streams because I'm
telling you I want to do that self-tying shabar stream. You can't see what I'm pointing at you
and waggling my finger like a teacher who knows you're up to no good because you copied off of
someone's homework. I'm very very excited for the power wash collab this week. That is going to be
funny as hell. I'm debating whether or not to stream my viewpoint. What do you guys think?
Like what do you want? Because it's going to be all of us streaming at the same time and I'm like
what's the point? I'm like I don't know. If you want me to see do you want to see my viewpoint?
I'm sorry I can't draw Rob Shibi. It's okay. A lot of the artists that will make commission for me
they always drew my ropes as straps. Like even my header art and my twitter and my wallpaper
that I also use it. It's just straps. It's just leather straps. It's not even rope or it looks
like ribbon. Give the clippers work. Hey Shibi I bought all 50 parts of the paper. Thanks for the
recommendation. Oh my god. That is such a just read like an excerpt from that book and you can
thank me later. I managed to shake down Emmy for the book title of the interesting book she wants
to read. I read the synopsis and I was like okay this is right up my alley all right. She's like
what? And I'm like yeah I'm on that shit and she's like oh okay and then I sent another
terrible fucked up smut book her way. I sent her den of vipers. I couldn't even get through that book
it was so bad. But I'm like I'm trying to try to convince management to give me a podcast with
um uh my IRL friend Salem because she also reads a lot of smutty books and and maybe Emmy and we
can have a little book club together and the other girls because I you know you know mercy reads that
shit you know she reads that shit you know and you would like you would like Salem she's cute and
funny maybe I'll drop a PNG for her. Mercy is say so she be. She's she's she's got you guys good huh
her sweet little yandere facade yeah yeah just wait just wait till she shows her true power
none of you will be safe. My GF right smut ironically I used to write so much
smut when I was younger. So Salem is what I call one of my um uh one of my best friends IRL. She is
uh very cute and funny she is adorable um she is way more base than I am.
You guys would like her a lot I might just I would probably be it wouldn't be like a live podcast
which definitely is like a pre-recorded thing um she heavily supports me v-tubing and she was so proud
of me um when I got accepted into VLR her and Olive which is one of my other IRL friends and Olive
is an actress so she was just like yeah entertainment industry so we're all creative types out here
uh bro mercy says she showers once a week and nothing sweet on that girl what do you mean
you know it's like when something smells so so bad that it almost smells like sourly sickly sweet
that's that's mercy there I say Salem for gen two no she got she got she does not have enough time
to be a vtuber she does not have time to be a vtuber she got she got a big girl job
envisioned the aroma I yeah I used to I used to write so much fucking smut when I was younger
I was no like me and my other my uh one of my childhood best friends um like I mentioned before
like we would do post by post role play a lot and then we realized oh my god we're we're good at writing
what if we wrote bad stuff and so we would get requests from other students on our our grade
mind you this was like fifth grade and we were known as like uh the the lemon girls
if you know what a lemon is
and some people would get us requests from their favorite characters and we would write like
we take like commissions and we'd be like all right and I'd be like uh insert this classmate's
name here with this character from this uh anime it was bad I remember one of the teachers um
um found one of the stuff because like we had a we had a notebook dedicated for that shit
I I think I threw it away when I was moving and I'm pissed at myself and my old sketchbook
because I would have led to show you guys my old sketchbook with all my OCs that I had
when I was like the ages of 12 to 18
dude write me in a jar jar banks do
did you do well in oh yeah no I I always had straight A's in my um my English classes my
literature classes and um and creative writing I remember in my creative writing class I wrote
I wrote so I had written this like really nicely done like introductory story almost
like an isekai but it was like to a different planet like again I would I really liked the
princess of mars like the john carter series so I was very heavily inspired by that and like the
main character was this dude they got abducted it was made into a slave for the queen of the
world and I like submitted that for the creative writing class and everybody was like wow this is
great and I'm like do you guys want to see the second chapter it's where they bang and my teacher's
like no no no no no no no no hold hold your horses hold your horses I fucking love my English teacher
shout out to mr redacted you were a real one if it wasn't for you I would not be the literary
genius I am today please give us a second chapter I still have it I still have it I still have
all of that I do have that one around mr redacted a real one he was like this really flamboyant
really short gated and he's like okay class so today I want you to write something that comes
from your soul okay I want you to write what you know and I'm like writes the most depressing
shit known to man and he's like chibi talk to me after this and I'm like
it's always the English teachers can you read the first yeah oh yeah and had one of my yeah I had
I wrote this whole thing yeah maybe I'll do I'll do a revisit of that we can reread my work
from I think I was like a junior or sophomore in high school
ironically a member's book book club would be probably I want to do that so bad it would be
so fucking we just read like smutty books though like really bad ones like maybe the first book
will be ice planet barbarians no eat my wet heart always take a sip of my tea
my high school English teacher loved listening to drama facts it was funny because like my
my biology teacher she was a fucking wackadoodle and she was awesome like we remember it for class
we watched like 28 days later and um was it not oh it started with a sea caught oh my god what the
fuck is that movie it's literally where everybody's sick and infection spreads throughout the entire
world it was literally like pre covid before covid um but and then she would just be like hey guys
let's go and put locker she just she just queue up the fucking movies we do that for class contagion
yes contagion contagion's a great fucking movie I love contagion really really bad wattpad stories
yes yes I let you know one of my guilty pleasures it was the um it used to be a wattpad series and
it blew up and they actually published it into books it's the after series now those are toxic
and terrible and then I watched the movies I still have to watch the last one me and me and
Salem and Olive uh would just go over Salem's house and we just laugh you know like uh what is
his name wanna I know like Chad Chad did a review of the after movies and so did um Connor was it
what's his name I don't know but um I don't I don't remember names okay I only remember faces um
that they just like did like making fun of it you know a movie is good when it's such a good
a pal for dying she's like my goop and then she just fucking gets got oh and like she would also
my balance she would just also just like blow up shit in class it was great I want English
teacher who uses all the laptops to see torrenting wait like after we collided yes yes bad Sean of
the dead great movie yeah I think did you ever watch to see the Jenna Nicholson video on the
One Direction X the Purse fan no I have to watch that work hard play harder yeah part is that should
be my my tagline your ex thought those movies were peak romance oh my god it's so bad that's toxic
is hell the main kiss so okay so let me explain to you what the after series is it is a One Direction
fan fiction where the main character is a self-insert of the author and she is in love with Harry
Styles except imagine Harry Styles having an alcoholic dad having an alcoholic problem of his own
being only like 18 or 17 uh beating people up doing drugs um imagine also having really bad anger
issues imagine uh uh Lewis and Zane and all the other ones as like side characters that try to
romance her but they're also toxic as hell exactly boomy um it was bad it was so bad like
it's so toxic like they'll just like you know like when you watch a romance movie and like the main
couple get like upset with each other but you know it easily could have been solved if they just like
said what was on their mind instead of or like asking for clarification because that was the
entire movie they just miscommunication between three movies hello hello welcome in
and oh you know a personal you know i i do like love the twilight movies when i say i love the
twilight movies i mean i've only seen like the first two and i need to watch the others because
it's a thing that me and my friend used to do every year where we would mute the twilight movie
and we would just dub over it with our own voices and pretend to know what was going on in the scene
and that was funny as hell titanic oh yes classic love story i'll never let go let's go easily could
have pulled them onto the door as well i hate that so much i tend to like talk a lot actually
you know it really depends um if i'm watching the movie with someone who's never watched it before
i will just shut up and i'll just like stare at the person be like i hope they like it but if it's
a movie i've seen a bunch of times and so it was like another person or my friends like me and my
friends we watch like mean girls and clueless every year we always watch mean girls on was it
october 5th or october 6th whatever the date was and um we would people still be calling me
shibidi toilet all these zoomers all these zoomers yeah get got mods slit his throat
hang him upside down bleed him let the pigs eat his blood in the muck thank you
uh talk a lot would never guess but um uh i'm really gonna say i'm not a zoomer
you just don't fucking eat it hey todo what's up girly pop
uh if you want to know someone who also yaps todo
my sweet tiger gal
i sent to the shadow realm me oh i love heathers i always like i always like sticking up my
middle finger i'd be like sitting on it and spin i love fucking saying that sit and spin
heathers is such a great movie i need to watch heathers again
mods give them negative social credit
means she is the biggest yapper in puller i i read that as i mean she is the biggest
plapper and vealer yappers for life moment of class okay looks like my cats have finally settled
down do you guys like the the pregame yappage tiger feature name checks out um
but uncomfortable i can't stop talking even though an introvert it's like you know like when
you're like you know you're really you have a special interest you really want people to enjoy it
yeah
fia the deathbed companion she's not even i was so happy so fia has been struggling like some of
you may know fia used to not be able to walk because she had some weird thing where she didn't
have use of any of her legs and i spent thousands of dollars i need to pay off my credit cards
over um trying to figure it out and so she's finally regained her walking ability but she was
struggling to jump and when i tell you this morning i cried because she jumped on the counter
and i haven't seen her jump in the longest time and it was so happy okay wait for cute she'd be
emotes my emotes are silly shawnee shawnee um uh commissioned dollar emotes and she's like i just
picked one step how you guys would like glad you're kidding but yeah yeah it was it was tough
it was like the little things like that were like really nice she's a she's a cute
best cat named after best girl yeah fia i'm like i don't know what to name you
and i just like i guess i was gonna name her um uh because like reina is like rain water
so lei was she was like sun fire boomi is earth and then i was like i couldn't think of like an air
related name i'm not gonna call her like sky or cloud or what have you and i'm like and i was
just playing elden ring and i'm like like an elden ring with my comfort game and i'm like america
i bring you in a court now um millennia i was like trying to say like pick up pick names
from my life like mog and then landed on fia but it's fun it works though because fia and i think
it's in check uh fiala means violet and she is a lilac point sime's lynx point and her the skin
and her ears isn't pink it's purple it's very cool so should i call her a turbulence
ang yes it's funny uh there's somebody in my building who is a dog named oppa and he's like
this cute little poodle and like when he the owner was like calling the dog into the elevator he
was like oppa yip yip and then the dog would come i was like oh my god armored core six one i might
have to throw them my my uh my throne or something fia hungas for the win if i ever get twin male
kittens i'm definitely named them mog and morgott oh i would a hundred percent do that
yeah i thought it was i thought it was so cute and it's cool i think uh emi's um watching uh
last airbender this week right isn't she i forget i can't believe she hasn't seen it
and i cry every time when she's like oh that old cartoon i'm like
coughs out dust because i'm 56
oh no where'd she go
oh
you watch the live action version live action version was actually okay they just skipped
over a bunch that was really it
it
it was a bit loud i literally turned the game volume down
i want to kill my mom
how about now i'm putting it down on the mixer rather than my audio through obs because i want
to make sure i'm able to hear any don't knows that come through
sounds okay better but now you get mog and morgott keep mog for michela please
oh yeah i i if fia was a boy i probably would have named her nick michela
okay cool we love to see it
by the way i freaking love that game thanks for introducing me to it
i'm even almost done with it which game call the lamb or class of oh nine
okay i peed this morning it smells like straight coffee because i drank like a
giant as coffee today and i'm still drinking it
mm so good they put the milk in but it's like it's been sitting with
like cinnamon toast toast crunch so like they use the milk it's like
called cereal milk coffee and i love it it's amazing okay let me let me eat it's my uh
wait you know what this calls for
so
pull down your pants and spread your mother fucking cheeks i'm going in raw
oh
hold on let me put my ooloo mouth on i love my ooloo mouth
you're bluffing
i'm not bluffing
but and it's not me that's going in it's the gun
i stay strapped you know i always stay strapped
wow i'm funny god damn wow
oh sorry
you have me on in the background
shibi is never lacking
louder louder for the people in the back
mercy what are you doing here hey you got a pistol permit for the piece you're packing
it's a god i was trying to think of a joke but it doesn't work because you still need a license for that
you got tickets to the gun show can't see but i'm flexing
and that's way too good hope you too doesn't pick up on that
jokes on you i have earbuds on your family didn't hear them too bad
i'm just saying if you're blasting me and you tell me that i'm within the background
i'm gonna do something out of pocket
the nine millimeters how big is your strap
the map is so cute it's literally it is elden ring ask okay so i remember i dropped and i lost everything
how do i play i have to remember how to play oh oh that's cool
50 i already talked to you
that's where i redo stuff
mom this is my rabbit girl apocalypse mad up girl apocalypse i'm the apocalypse
oh my game be lagging am i lagging
okay we get uh we got stop motion shibi today because i guess my internet should be again
all right
i was trying to walk around
oh fuck uh what
i forget how to play hold on
just just just give me a moment
my model is probably lagging because of the game yeah definitely is
what the scallop
how do i get to the settings please
okay i don't get to
so i'm just gonna change the graphics on this that's fine
a few minutes in we're already scuffed how do i
how do i do that again okay yeah yeah yeah oh wait wait uh wait which button is it
what fucking button is it no it's not that not that i just pressed that it's not that
that's what it is that's that's the trigger
oh that's pretty sick actually oh nice sweet so i don't gotta go through all that again
okay so okay my stuff's over there
cool cool cool
tweet oh fuck i never tweeted that i was live
i literally have twitter open because i was going to do it because somebody already mentioned it
hello it is me your mother she be calling i am live
please pick up the phone and stop leaving me
me
me on voicemail or you're gonna get grounded perfect i think that's pretty good
where's the little red symbol for live i hate this okay cool
then i gotta retweet it to my fucking old account
who's it has a bunch of bots that i would like the support of
all right perfect
you know what he just realized my door has been unlocked this entire fucking time
and also what's less has been unlocked when i took a shower
i'm gonna get abducted i don't do this on purpose i'm just forgetful
i'm not you know
i remember i told my parents that like i've done that sometimes i mean sometimes i mean a lot
my mom my mom's like no no it was my dad he's like i don't know how you're not dead yet
my mom's like i check the door five times before i go to bed i'm like yeah mom because
we both have ocd she's like what and i'm like anyways tell me more about gardening
oh i hate it here
how do i heal that's not it
nope
there we go
oh hey you want a cigarette kid where'd that go well actually i really don't need that
i matter okay can i use those scissors as a weapon instead
oh didn't mean to do that please
there we go you guys can't jump
haha oh i'm gonna die
okay so you fly over here
what you fly over here god damn it
what is she happen about i just don't worry about it don't worry about my yappage
i am close to death but it's fine
boomi why you got your toes out like that now i gotta now i gotta now i gotta touch those beans
bro you know beans oh sweet little pinto beans
sweet little little black frijoles frijoles negro she said what no relax
all right i'm naked okay we're back now i know what i'm doing don't worry about it
we're good we're in the hood we're maxing we're crab maxing
i'm a pro souls like gamer
pro souls like gamer there is nothing over here that i needed
we're focused we're locked in we're thriving we're unbothered we're beautiful oh he's dead
we're running for our lives
see my stuff is uh over oh what's that hello
how the fuck do i get over there
hmm i wonder if at some point you get more jump
because i can't like launch myself over there the visuals remind me of the old
spongebob game that's right actually
no we are flourishing we are unbothered there is no fall damage we are recovering our junk
we are running away we are running away we are running away we are picking this up
we are jumping on you what the fuck am i doing where am i why can't i just collect
all the micro plastics in the air
the fuck is that oh no
is this something i'm gonna have to fight can i save
oh whatever
damn it i was hoping i would never have to fight a boss in this game
what the fuck is this
why is this such a bomb
hold on i'm like enjoying the music i want to get up and dance
shit
oh fucking pop off
uh uh uh let's get it
this goes hard
go okay i need to shake my ass oh let's go
um
it's fortnite move man i need a 3d model so bad
it's like fucking step off step step up step up the streets
that wasn't my butt
i spilled my tea on myself
okay now i'm now i'm feeling motivated oh perfect
can i
oh
like how he's like randomly deagroed
why does this go so hard
hmm
i was hoping it would like try to attack me so i can see the move set but all right
what the fuck
oh damn it i didn't know i was gonna swing another time
damn
oh
oh i rolled into that
i
oh interesting okay take a girl out to dinner first won't you oh hello
ujiro hanmer tipped six dollars that's so fucking loud truly harder than from soft game ever made
you would be correct
in a way
sis but all of these spots yesterday's listen listen
where am i oh sick okay we're good we're good i got i'm confident
now we know what this homeboy is about and now i i got my dancing all done
so we're gonna do a little bit of this
oh
why am i uh i need to get the timing right on this game
what the best thing to do is to
roll in front of him
i'm gonna die a lot
okay he does it three times okay and he followed up with that didn't expect it
all right all right
oh my god
did i bug him out
i don't know what happened
oh
oh okay
no
thank god for the checkpoint you got that more god stick attack
okay
you can do it yeah
take a girl out to dinner first won't you oh thank you for the tip by the way
ujiro
no no that's not gonna be me thank you anonymous that's gonna be
that's gonna be momo momo is gonna do that
momo is the best girl gamer that ever lived
i think she is playing elden ring soon i think she's i don't know what sort of run
she's going for i can't recall
what the hell are you doing
cats making noises uh mama is the elden lord exactly i'm like
i'm like her i'm like her squire
all right stop the bomb music again
bro i fucking i need a trap remix of this
it's not gonna
climb
whoa
i can't i am stuck okay
oh
well i'll fuck up even let's go she be believers
uh i don't even know what what thing this is
who is this my fourth attempt
okay okay all right all right all right all right okay no ladies
oh i fucked myself up there i didn't mean to press that button
oh
what the hell he has another hand he can use his other hand
like i ninja run
um
he wasn't using his other arm before
damn it i was hoping he was going to do the jump forward attack
but i when he gets to halfway is when he does both hands
using your other hand is a good skill to have it's annoying that there's no light
shells in that area the dodge window with medium shells one bit brutal yeah
you know bring up the strong hand i think of that like scary movie with the guy with
those little hands
why i didn't why isn't it working oh my god come closer please
so
I guess I rolled into that and I didn't run up close enough.
There's a parry mechanic. I still haven't gotten the timing yet. It's like really weird.
I can parry like a fucking god and Liza P but
in this game I'm just not good.
Okay it's important to do it only when it's close.
Oh fuck I ran past one.
There is a light shell it's right there.
I might actually wait you can't reach me if I'm up here.
Ah bitch come closer.
Why don't you get around that little thing so I can do this.
We're just gonna look at each other.
He has some beautiful eyes. They have a certain glow to them. Did you know that?
I can literally kind of cheese him like this.
Just stay up here and every time I like land a hit on him
I get more umami but that would just take forever though.
You're so beautiful I can't stop looking at you.
Hold on let me look at chat.
I know the parry yet should be obvious in the game once you unlock it though.
I thought the parry is the shell.
Am I playing a mage? I'm a crap.
Cheat strat. I can't run past them the place is blocked.
How would I run past the boss?
I wonder if this one will glitch like the other one did and just let me hit my little heart
and let me um pass.
Can I have this? Why are you stuck to me?
I'm gonna die. I need to run into a can.
Oh that's the one that's broken.
Where's the other can?
Oh god what does this one do? What's the pop-off do I forget?
I rolled. Oh I hate it here.
I don't even know what the fuck pop-off even does.
Just fucking kill me. I don't even care at this point.
This should only let you guard her first.
Are you serious? Why don't they let me parry right away?
I'm starting to get angry because I suck. I need to get good.
Okay so there's one right there, one right there.
So I got one, two, three, four chances.
I can also run up here.
Like this is also a spot I can like run away from.
I like wasted it though.
Can I hit you?
Okay you can still hit me up here but not that well though.
Is this a strat? Keep him in the corner.
I think it's a strat.
Yep it's a strat.
I am in the map.
It could be one of those bosses you're gonna come back later when you're powerful enough.
No it's not. This is where I need to go to progress.
I forgot I just like jumped down one time. Oh I fucked myself.
I fucked myself my last run because oh I don't even fucking give a shit anymore.
I think this is the cheese strat.
Thrust is so hard to say through a wall. All right come here big boy.
If he jumps you can make it up there.
Come here. Come over here. Come here. Get over here please.
Haha you fucking miss bitch. Suck my titties.
Oh buddy.
Oh.
Then he'll usually go at me with that. Okay.
You're a crab not a scorpion.
Seems like the game wants you to get good at dodging heavy attacks.
Well I'm not going to so this is how I play.
Did I or did I not roll out of the fucking way for that? What the fuck is my hitbox dude?
See you just fucked myself again.
Remember the fives of dodgeball? I watched that movie again recently.
Fives of dodgeball be a pussy.
Is there like lag to when I fucking dodge?
I am really pressing the fucking roll button.
You actual fucking cocksucker. I swear to...
Get out of my face. Get out of my fucking face.
Come closer.
Sorry I'm a mad.
I ran into that.
I'm a little confused because
my shell doesn't take the brunt of the heavy attack.
When he goes into a second phase he just kills me.
When it's in his first phase and he does a heavy attack it just breaks my shell.
I don't quite understand that.
I need an audio or mad. I'm as mad as that or more.
Like I usually don't like playing souls likes on stream because I get really angry
and I personally don't think it's the funnest gameplay to watch to just watch someone be angry
and not be good at a game. Like if you're like angry and then you like kill the boss in your
third try you'd be like all right that's pretty sick. But it's like when it's like 20 tries in
and you're like what the fuck like I remember I had a like that stupid clown boss from Lies of P
took me like three hours of trying in a stream ended up spiking my headphones and breaking
them and smashing them through my controller on the ground almost broke my monitor
and then in the next two runs I finally beat him but I did that all off stream
because I didn't want anybody to see
because it's you it's unfortunate training
I'm good as long you're having good time well like no like I'm enjoying myself playing like
because I like I don't mind Ragey games like this it's just that I personally can't watch somebody
play it with something because in my head I tend to backseat and I get frustrated I'm like just
fucking beat like you could have just done that there you couldn't like that's how I like watch
people who play these games so I get mad watching people play these games and they suck at them
like me because like I would go back and watch my vlogs and I'm like I'm such a fucking idiot where
the fuck did I do that all right
hmm
okay he clips through that so I don't want to
I like I literally will jump and it takes forever I'm like is it my controller
I have like a fucking Thunderbolt C so it's not like is it the cable I don't
why is there such a delay in my like I'm pressing stuff before it happens and then it happens a second later
so
at least you get stuck on that little embankment so I can chill for a second
huh uh I just choked on my spit
do you have dead zones on what's that
I didn't feel like there was a delay when I was playing so it could be an issue
controller dead zones can delay you I don't know what that means
maybe we should hit the boss a little bit then back away hit him again thanks Sachiko aren't you
a fucking genius bro it's medium weight dodge roll is it is it really the dodge roll
yo how you been snowflake this is what the fuck I'm not icy
dead zones are like how far you move the stick until registers an input
maybe it's a ps5 controller
okay he's kind of stuck on that
how the how the fuck did he run after me so fast
okay he's on this
he's on the piercing part of his face
oh I thought I had some can you come over here instead you come over here
can you come over here can you come over this way this way good puppy come on
be a good dog and listen
to defeat blue poops a firefighter attack until it dies oh my god you wanna thank you oh my god
have you tried dodging no oh my god I need to try dodging have you tried lowering its HP
oh my god you got why didn't I try this before holy crap I'm so dumb sometimes you know
I need it to go over that way
oh
I got a bog
have you tried shooting it hold on hold on hold on
all right let's see if shooting it helps
I wish I had a toggle on this so that it would show like a muzzle flash
okay
schnog that needs it to what
this is staying alive y'all are so smart the strap's back the strap stays on during
oh okay he managed to hit me that time oh wait no blue hoof
okay I'm good
cool
what
run away I'm trying like I even press B no it's even like B
like to run it takes me it's an extra just like a second delay
there's a hundred percent a like a one second delay when I do anything
he's on my booty hole he is on my booty cheeks
all right we're getting somewhere he's really locked on to me
he's gonna I'm gonna run past him and bait his attacks
oh well come on come on
you're gonna do anything or
come on
there it is waiting for him to do this stabby thing because the stabby thing has the most range
yeah there it is yeah he does that four times
yeah and then he's gonna punch me oh please don't die I'm so close
okay
thank god can we try putting the controller in the dishwasher
all right bait some attacks out come on come on
thank you
everyone clap your pussy lips just like this
give it to me don't stop don't diss
how many pearls do I need to bring back to that lady
uh madam's hand so what what oh what do you have no hands how did you type that
uh oh wait I meant like
you know how many pussy lips clap clap your ass cheeks then
all right it's funny that I won when I had the gun
when in doubt bring the Glock out that's all I'm gonna say
okay
wait could I have run past the bosses entire time
I don't know
no I don't think so I don't think I could have
oh what's this I didn't mean to press that
you got a nice place here moon moon snail I'm gonna who am I talking to oh
oh wait holy crap I thought are you on are you this whole fucking mass Jesus fuck you're huge
the gun adds plus ton attack
as long last the hermit crab lays eye in the powerful eyes sorry when the powerful
waterline sensual body of the snail hi uh thanks for leaving me here I think the duchess is
really gonna like this pearl but I still need a way to get out of this cave in order to progress
the hermit crab will need to further expand on its omami abilities
I don't think I can do the ash catching voice it's creating my my throat
cool how do I do that I'm getting to a dam
I mean um the hermit crab closes his eyes and allows himself to become one with the waves
he notices the effect on his body has on I can't read the currents around him
and lets himself be changed by them in turn okay
hey when I close my eyes I can start to see something I see a tree some sort of tree of skills
shell deportation oh
I have every single thing leaves currents in the wake in its wake why can't I read today
as it travels through his ocean this ocean I have dyslexia
be it a living person a beast a corpse but even a piece of garbage
gabbage the life force of the ocean the beating heart of this world
this phenomenon is known as umami invisible to most umami currents can be detected only
by chosen few excuse me even fewer still can make use of them oh the glowing purple stuff
I've seen that surrounding some big shells and crystals out there
surprising I guess I didn't you know zap you that I mean um
the hermit crab's training may progress faster than anticipated
he feels that perhaps if he enters a discarded moon snail shell a new use for it's might reveal itself
the dyslexia whose dyslexia must be a baddie
yeah that was that was the snail that wasn't me guys
you can read not really shell deporting
that's the same sound I swear that's used by
I call the lamb for something
uh much money I got
fuck your mother
what sort of build should I go for guys
shell collection oh shit
even if I get the shell it doesn't have a spell on it
fast tonight in uh I had I played only three hours of balder's gate three
and I got bored and I haven't played it since
gun build
but I feel like maybe if I because I think I went into the game expecting I guess Scott
because I've never played any game like I never played um uh well I did play like dragon age
inquisition I didn't like it either um I didn't I thought balder's gate would play more like
like skyrim does or like oblivion and it doesn't I'm not a huge fan of turn-based games the only
like turn-based game I'm a fan of is fire emblem three houses
okay now where the fuck do I go oh I need to teleport back we need to talk to you again
the hermit crab returns prepared to augment his abilities oh sick oh I have more oh shit
oh give me that Jesus fuck
hermit crab shells and valuable and protect him from predators protect him not to see this
from a sense of aggression
thank you
okay
Jesus I'm just killing everybody
okay so let me just oh I can refund skills fascinating press x to jump the press oh my god
thank you
release button right before enemy attack lands
okay
that's a night in
is there a way to reduce that controller like stuff
like it in my I don't know if it's the because I never had this problem with lies of pee
don't quite understand it okay I have to teleport back
you
harlots are sassy today
she hates to be RPGs um should check out outer worlds I've been told to play outer worlds
I was getting out of scrolls I too polar opposite of RPG that's what I mean I realized I like elder scrolls
polar pull of RPGs so if they reload I've actually never played for any persona game
through I wish they had something more open world probably like follow new bangas yeah
a vowed coming what's a vowed bear what a collab with the girls playing oh yeah no I
would totally play with them might just be the games built in input lag maybe
yeah screw the storyline it's all that matters this game looks like Elden Ring I don't know
I don't know fucking Elden Ring you've been playing
um yeah I know strong he's gonna be playing Elden Ring every go a type of run she's doing
I uh I will maybe all get Elden Ring since people keep asking why did I I meant to
teleport I get distracted maybe I'll play if enough people want me to after she plays
um can marry Ronnie or something because I got the frenzied flame ending last time I played
can you tell me how taxes work the hem at crab nose instinctively to stop pushing luck
I like that character I like the moves now character
wait does Elden Ring Elden Ring looks like this game
okay am I tripping or before the song started did it go one two three four
because I heard a whisper of a voice and I'm scared I'm losing my mind
you got the Elden Ring deal yeah I got um shout-outs of the air tree a little bit
earlier than most it's pretty sick uh where do I go is it this way is there a map
I think it's this yeah it's this way
mr crab war why is it so fucking dark over here
what the fuck
what happened oh no
I've been standing watch my whole life for what got nothing in return stupid stupid
hey excuse me I gotta get back in and see the Duchess again keeps piling up all the trash all the
work are you like okay man or sick of it sick to death of all of it
it's all so worthless no I don't want to fight you oh anyways
no are you stuck
aw little guys stuck jeez what the fuck happened to you
do I want to even try to kill you
I could use the micro plastics I don't like
actually you seem like you have as much like a little bit less
health than the other dude actually no yeah I can kill you what
okay you're done did I parry I don't think I parried there but whatever
if you're beating Elden Ring how come you just suck so much of this game that's a great question
actually I didn't like beat Elden Ring in a short amount of time I did it in like 150 hours or more
it's like a long clam
oh uh can you not kill me oh
okay
all right I like this power actually
oh so if I do the run and lunging attack I want to run lunging attack okay cool
cool cool
every souls game I could use the blank I can kill you jumps on the sword I didn't mean I don't
even know how I jumped on the sword
to be fair Elden Ring dodge is better than this game here you're supposed to block parry more
than dodge it seems like it Elden Ring isn't a cleverly disguised platformer now that's
eyes of pee those lobsters were using straws isn't that enough straw sample player second power
oh I have to go around see this crab
oh what the fuck
are you serious I don't know you're fucking behind me
any more like Sakura I guess
oh Elden Lord she be what is your wisdom for the day
uh do not use a three in one shampoo
can I have a shell please
oh
what I'm literally gonna die these stupid little weird things
uh
what can I not reach that are you serious
you're kidding me right
why is there a battery look at
zen gunman tipped four dollars thank you zen fun fact hermit crabs are not crabs but shrimp
what zero tents worst game my disappointment is immeasurable and my day is ruined
is that true
wait actually no I was going off the beaten path for a second
are they really actually you know what kind of makes sense
just because of the little bodies have you ever seen a hermit crab out of its shell they look
fucking gross
four slacktide
oh you that's where you are
oh my god
what's that under there
how's something that's fucking just stabbing my leg
justice show the hermit crabs of Pagore that are mostly closer to squat lobsters
porcelain crabs and they are true crabs
you tell me shrimp hermitted this crab
what the fuck
can you chill out dude
can't jump I'm stuck
are you serious
oh thank god I was supposed to be very upset
get me out of this hell
hell
running attack that didn't work oh I don't want to die
I forget I don't have a fucking shell
got to go fast I'm so happy there is no stamina in this game though maybe that's why
there's input lag
look at that imprint this
they only have four toes oh no one two three four oh yeah they were just overlapping
I don't want to die dies anyway it's you know it's how it be sometimes at least he
doesn't respond again because I would have been annoying
move bitch get out the way get out the way bitch get out the oh oh please don't fucking kill me
I will literally on a live myself in Minecraft
can you fall off oh perfect love to see it um there is that little stuff over there I presume
might go this way oh I could jump over there for that so I shall
I like that stuff flies away um when you hit it
um
wait where the fuck am I supposed to go
okay Jesus how could I feel the vibrations of him running at me and doing an attack and it's crazy
haha fuck you
strong grippers I am a tiny little guy I'm just a little guy I'm a little dude uh doing dude things
where am I supposed to fucking go oh fuck me oh fuck me bro
oh cap no cap
where am I
I don't even know where the fuck I'm going
oh excuse me
oh um well bye
okay I did successfully parry there
oh thank god thank god big meaty cloche
nope let me just teleport to the side there gotta go fast faster faster faster faster should be x
um I'm putting my attack up
oh
oh sorry sometimes you just gotta moan um
where my stole is
okay
what are adaptations interesting
all right uh came from there I'm normally you probably have to progress this way
um but yeah that's the crab that fucking almost killed me I'm gonna say almost I mean it killed me
uh something's probably gonna pop up over here
no okay
those dudes are fucking dead
um I'm so I don't know how like the lobster was locked on on me when I'm literally up here
where do I get to the main castle gates oh no platforming
hello I was disgusting do it again
meunga yubunga the four kids song I've seen it it really did though uh no I don't listen to carty
where am I supposed to go to oh okay
please don't fucking fall oh great probably knock you off
yeah see I like I even like it there's input lag because um I didn't press the button again
after uh oh that's kind of cool that I can do that on here after it died
can't go that way
I can literally just stay on this and just jump not the deal with them
um
got this yes I probably have to like fight the queen or something or the duchess
doesn't make any sense because then I wouldn't need to pay my taxes anymore
where'd he go team rocket blasting off again am I going to the surface I'm so close to the
surface right now
oh yeah I'm definitely gonna have to do a boss battle in a moment
um
I'm letting go
hmm
I mean something is up here oh what that
I could have sworn I already collected three of those blood star things
yeah I thought it was said three I guess it's four
oh here where the options are haha perfect
okay
assist what's assist mode what does assist mode
oh it's the
heart is a default okay
give krill a gun there's a gun I can give him a gun
well die the die instantly is good if you get if you get stuck somewhere and you can't get out
um I kind of want to see what the gun thing is
I can recover micro plastics
will that help
maybe
okay
Okay, I'm ready to play now.
Alright, I just want to know how this works.
I can't go that way.
Go fucking run!
You're gone for a sentence for you to run in.
You know what it locks? I don't even have to do anything.
Give me that.
What is this?
Oh, sick.
Oh, cool.
Oh, because I probably got to go over.
What the fuck?
Why can't I?
I can't shoot him.
It wouldn't let me lock on.
Wait, wait, hold on. Can you come back?
It literally is a one hit kill.
Alright, I'm ready to face the boss.
That's for sure.
Oh, I can't fucking jump though.
Wait, let me...
I'm a battle crab.
Let me swap real quick.
I'll grab the- I don't know how a gun works underwater.
Come on, I can't make that.
Perfect.
Oh, sick.
Where do I- is this a-
Oh, that's cool.
Kind of just kamikaze yourself.
Alright, grab that gun.
Nice. I don't know how I can pull the trigger.
Are you alive?
You fucking dead? Oh my god, he's fucking dead.
Alright, bitch.
I'm fucking ready.
What is wrong with you?
What the fuck?
Oh, shuck.
Did you see the gun in my ass in the cutscene?
Is oil making all the animals crazy?
The fish crazy?
The crustacean's crazy.
Well, I have a fucking gun, so...
All of our lives are a sand beneath the tide. You'll see.
I didn't think it would one-shot her.
I thought it would take a bunch of hits on her.
At least five or something.
Holy abalone!
That was a show of a fight, kid, was it?
You were watching the whole thing?
I guess it was too much to ask the soldiers caught you, jerk.
No such luck. I hit as soon as everyone started going crazy.
Who the fuck is controlling me?
That's the five I never picked a fight he doesn't have up to.
He could learn a thing or two from a guy like me.
Well, now the judges says, you know...
So give me my shot back. You have no reason to keep anymore, right?
Huh, this whole thing, you know, I can barely remember how I got my fins on it anymore.
Thinkin' I might just go pawn this off in the big city?
Make myself a few microplastics?
What? What? You can't do that!
I will shoot you into the motherfucking gun.
You're using a human-sized gun and a crab.
I think it's gonna one-shot her.
And that's how you afford a fake taxes.
It's the gun I described earlier, about 100% chance of incident.
Oh!
Excuse me. Oh, so I can do anything he wants.
He's gonna get away with, kid.
See me a new carcinia.
Carcinia.
English. If you wanna buy this bad boy back from me.
If no one else buys it first, that is.
No!
When I get my hands on that guy, I swear, I don't have hands, I have claws.
I swear I'm gonna shoot him.
You have wearing your first adaptation attack.
Wearing from a powerful creature that can be used without even a shell equipped.
Okay, my cat is looking at my foot.
Raina, what are you doing?
Okay.
Oh, that's not it.
The fuck? Where did this come from?
Oh.
Cool.
Okay, but it needs to.
Alright.
She be in the hood.
Let me put the gun away.
I feel like I just cheated. I didn't think that was gonna happen.
It's fine. I probably would have cried for five hours anyways.
Gonna cheese the whole game with the gun.
I'm tempted to.
But I won't.
How does this stay on my ass?
Alright.
I'm just gonna turn that off.
Can I go back? Okay.
I need a...
So, can you hear my controller click when I'm like...
That's like the timing is...
Literally like a half a second off.
So, I'm seeing it putting up the settings.
Yeah, exactly. That's why I'm like...
I'm like, guys, I swear to you, I'm not usually this bad.
Like, I decently got through Lies of Pea
and Elden Ring. It's just such as a fucking delay.
If I put it up to 200, it will happen.
I can't even tell if that's any better.
Maybe PC is better? Let me see.
That is a little bit better.
How do I...
Yeah, it's actually a lot more responsive on PC.
But Jesus fuck, it changes my mouse sensitivity to the fucking moon.
Can I please fucking scroll down?
Can I please scroll down?
Tap the... What the fuck are these tap...
These fucking bindings.
I can't even use... I can't even use the buttons on the side of my mouse.
Oh, Jesus fuck.
Turn the arm on, see it.
Okay.
I feel like it's a little bit better.
No, it's not.
The dodge is better but the attack isn't.
Okay.
No, literally when you turn on this game it says it's best with a controller.
Have you considered simply getting good as the kids say?
You're only as good as your equipment.
That's what they say.
Skins equals wins.
Counter strike.
My need to assign it the mouse down column to the keyboard one.
Let me try that.
Because I'll play with keyboard if that works, if it's better then.
Actually...
...
Jesus fuck.
You always run faster with a knife.
Boobs counts as equip.
Holy moly.
Yes, you like my equipment?
You like my equipment?
Actually, I would prefer...
...
... because I'm thinking about how I play...
... FPS games.
...
The fuck was left control being used for?
Heal, that's fine.
F, that's fine.
Shell spell.
Okay, I was going to use Q for that, but Q's already there.
Hammer.
Folk, oh, focus.
What the fuck, hammer?
What the fuck is C being used for?
C's not being used for anything, am I blind?
...
God, why the fuck am I...
Why is my eye burning?
That's not what I fucking pressed!
No!
Actually...
Yeah, whatever.
It doesn't have any, like, mouse sensitivity.
Oh, turn that off.
Everything's off!
What?
Oh, my fucking god.
It took the mouse right thing as, like...
I can't move my fucking camera, even though I didn't press mouse right.
Shell spell on C?
I really want some crab legs now.
Please, for the love of god, let me move down.
Oh.
What?
Just because I moved my mouse to the...
Jesus.
What is m-
What?
Game is weird.
Okay.
Let me just...
I put...
I don't like using keyboard in a game like this,
because I literally... it takes me forever to, like, get the...
bindings I want.
Why is that?
It was using this as a sprint.
Okay.
Okay, whatever.
You guys, you guys hang in there?
Do you have a controller plugged into a USB header,
in the case of the motherboard?
It's on the motherboard,
and it's USB-C it's plugged into,
so that's why I'm like, what the fuck?
Ooh, give me that.
You know what I should have done? I should have leveled up.
Can I go back to that moonshell?
You guys are chilling? You're dead? I'm so sorry.
No loss.
No loss there.
No one will miss you.
Okay.
PC of Bluetooth.
I don't think it does.
I feel like even if it was Bluetooth, it wouldn't make a difference.
If I...
So I have to go to the lady to do my skill tree?
Yes, for sure.
Hello.
I don't think a spirit could type,
but well, maybe if it's a talented spirit.
You have steam input enabled?
I don't know.
I don't know where that setting would be.
I usually... I've never had that enabled that I know of.
I don't need to talk to you, I just need to...
Do I need to talk to you to upgrade stuff?
Am I just going here to do that?
No?
Okay, I guess I have to talk to you.
I guess you're the Sophia in this game.
Oh!
Cool.
That's pretty smart.
Fashion night in?
Hmm, these are all really good skills to use.
Yeah.
That's cool, actually.
I think I might do the free...
Actually, I'll do that, yeah.
I hate playing on keyboard, though.
Phew.
You have the same utility disabled it?
Oh.
Pushing to Bluetooth, which I helped you.
Where is this... where is steam input?
Where would that setting be?
Sorry, I'm stupid.
Sorry, I'm blonde.
Where would this be input setting be?
Hmm.
Oh, shit, I just realized what time it was.
I am gonna end it here for now.
I think Amy's on doing stuff.
Let me save.
I don't know if I'm gonna keep playing this game.
The whole thing with the controls is kind of irritating.
But if you guys really want me to continue...
Oh, yeah, she's designing a 2.0 outfit or something.
And then...
Bye, big sis.
Yeah, I'm gonna send you to little sis.
I was just starting to enjoy this.
Damn.
If you guys really want me to continue it, I will.
It's like clamoring for it.
Maybe I will.
I don't know.
I probably won't play it next week, maybe the week after.
I like the game.
Again, I don't like being irritated and frustrated with the game's mechanics on stream.
Maybe a gun run?
No, that'd be too fucking easy.
I don't want to make it easy.
I'm generally mad that I killed the Duchess in one shot.
I thought it would take at least two, three, or four or five shots.
I feel like such a fucking dirty cheater.
I'm mad at myself.
Just like when the weird bug that the first boss you fight just disappeared on me and didn't show back up.
And everybody treated it like I killed it.
But I'm like, he just leapt.
He didn't want to talk to me anymore.
What the fuck is on my arm?
Yeah, the controls are rushing.
That's the most anticlimactic.
What do you think that happened?
I know.
I'm like, okay.
I was like righty coming up with another strat.
I'm like, okay, I just got to like bring him in a circle, be able to jump in a can for a shell.
And then he just never showed up.
He never showed up for the fight.
I fear you're a maiden list.
I don't have any sort of maiden list behavior.
Downloading.
I'm lost to my phone right now.
Also hi, hi.
Yeah, going on and off.
Like, yeah, I might play this a little bit on the side.
I have Sekiro.
Heroes die twice.
So maybe I'll play that.
I'm trying to think of some games to play for next week.
I'm thinking about doing some collabs next week.
It's frustrating.
I have to miss out on a possible collab with the girls next week because I have to work at my normal job again.
Sekiro, yeah, I only got.
So Sekiro was the first friend like Soulslight game I ever played.
And I didn't know what Soulslikes were like.
I didn't know it was a Soulslight.
I didn't, I didn't, I never had played Dark Souls or anything.
And I remember, like, I never got past the first boss, like the first duty fight, because I was, I was just getting so pissed and angry.
I'm like.
Thank you, Mama.
I'm glad you liked it. It was kind of funny.
I can't, I want a clip of that.
Just like of me getting the gun and being like, wait, let's see how this works.
And just fucking one shot.
It's good.
Play Dark Souls too.
Yeah.
Yeah, let me know what, like, I also have Liza P.
I wouldn't mind playing through Liza P again.
On stream.
That's a game I really enjoyed.
Yeah.
Curl becoming an American moment.
I wish there was like dialogue, though, like when you added that, like when you got, when you got the gun.
I wish you would like, say something.
Like, really, really, like, really awkwardly political.
Like, they may get my taxes, but they'll never take my gun right away.
There's some shit like that.
Play Doom.
The new Doom game that's coming out looks good.
I, like, I, I was like, holy shit, that looks good.
I haven't, I've never played Doom.
I've never played Doom.
I was like, holy shit, that looks good.
I have, I've never played Doom.
I'll be honest with you.
I've never played a Doom game.
I've always wanted to play a Doom game.
My dad, I think, played the OG Doom game.
I've watched people play Doom, and I do like, shoot him up.
This should make us be gonna make sure we text an accent.
Yeah.
Peak America is Texas.
Can't wait for that state to just secede from our country and become the country of Texas.
Or something.
I don't care who the IRS is saying, I'm not paying my taxes.
It's fucking WAPOW.
Shoot some.
Hell yeah, brother.
Okay, let me make sure my redirect's good, and I'll send you on over to Sweet Emmy.
Doom, Doom, Doom, Doom, Doom, Doom, Doom, Doom, Doom, Doom, Doom, Doom, Doom, Doom, Doom, Doom, Doom.
Yay.
Okay, that is cool.
Designing group 2.0.
I love how the thumbnail is Twilight Sparkle yelling at something.
I might be, I'm cooking something behind the scenes for my 2.0.
Actually, it's not even a 2.0, it's more of a 1.5.
But that won't be for until maybe next year.
No, maybe it'll be a 2.5 if I get a 2.0 by like the end of the year.
I don't know.
Who knows?
I do like this model.
I mostly just want more toggles.
And I was telling Azura pointed out that we actually are missing a vowel when we talk.
Which is, because you got A, E, I, O, U, but U doesn't work.
So I do U, U, U, my mouth isn't open.
So it's weird.
Yeah, Nari did a great job rigging.
Yeah.
Gould did a great job designing.
Well, thank you for the tips guys.
I hope you have a great rest of your day or night and hanging out with Emmy.
I also hope you suck a dick because, you know, you're trash and all, so.
It's all that trash is good for.
Sucking peepie.
Lots of love.
XOXO.
Madam Sheeby.
You guys still smell bad though.
I'm sorry.